Dot voting or zen voting allows you and
your team to zero in on the best ideas.
This activity is actually
a part of the decide stage, but
it can follow the crazy 8s or
any rapid sketching that you do.
In zen voting, you lay out all
the sketches on a table or
you tape them to a wall.
Then, you give everyone a limited number
of sticker dots, usually two or three.
And you have people silently pick the
best ideas by placing their sticker dot
on that sketch.
It's important for the voting to be
silent, so people can choose without
being easily persuaded by
the loudest person in the room.
After voting, you and
your team can discuss the best ideas.
Take a minute to think
about your sketches and
the example sketch that was
provided from the Crazy 8s.
Which two ideas did you like the best?
After you've made up your mind,
check this box to continue.